[Musique]
il y a différentes zones de rayonnement
dans l'espace s'étirant comme une telle ceinture
s'étendent autour de la terre qui sont élevés
électron et proton énergétiques
sortir du soleil
c'est vraiment si fort
Dommages cellulaires causés par celui-ci
peut ou des mutations dans le
cellules qui à leur tour conduisent au cancer
mène et au point où vous n'avez qu'à
en tant qu'astronaute, assurez-vous que vous
assurez-vous de ne pas
est affectée
[Musique]
donc des figures féminines à cause de ça ou
figures ou fantômes
parce que le risque possible de rayonnement nous le
Exposition aux radiations des femmes à l'extérieur
Nous avons toujours été intéressés par l'espace extra-atmosphérique
plus d'astronautes c'est super oui et
sont juste de retour sur le
station spatiale
nous allons alors aussi
Les équipages ont du nord à l'intérieur du
puis vole vers la lune et sur la lune
atterrira et nos questions
était d'accord comment est le risque radiant
pour les femmes pour des missions de longue durée
espace
[Musique]